on this tuesday night political change
and fresh faces in alberta politics
[Music]
historic victories in the province's two
largest cities we have made
the impossible possible i will be with
you every step of the way as we
encounter the unknown my one-on-one with
calgary's next mayor joe t gondeck the
uphill battle to keep covet cases down
what one saskatchewan city is now
considering plus what's being reviewed
as covid vaccines for children await
approval
and open mic on mars
wind gusts and wheels crunching what
sounds from the red planet reveal
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with political changes in
alberta politics that are getting
noticed across the country voters in the
province's two biggest cities have made
history electing two people of color in
edmonton former liberal cabinet minister
amrajeet sohi who says he immigrated to
canada from india with nothing at the
age of 18 has been elected mayor taking
over from dawn iverson and in calgary
former city councilor jody gondek was
elected to replace nahed nenshi becoming
the first female mayor in calgary's
history
what changes will these new mayors usher
in and what do their wins reveal about
politics in alberta heather urex west
has our top story tonight
it is not a marathon but an ultra super
duper marathon
inside calgary city hall it's a
transition among allies as outgoing
mayor nahad nenshi prepares to turn over
the city to former councilor now
mayor-elect jody gondek the progressive
candidate won easily monday night with
45 percent of the vote it will now be an
honor to serve as your mayor
wow and support you
gondek is joined in edmonton by fellow
progressive and former federal liberal
cabinet minister amarjeet sohi i'm
absolutely excited
to
be
elected
to lead our city into the next chapter
there's so many so much good stuff going
on in our city am i surprised that both
major cities elected
progressive and progressive ishmael's
absolutely not
analyst zane velgey says voters in
calgary and edmonton have been
supporting progressive municipal
candidates for years but this election
he believes made a statement about the
deeply unpopular provincial government
as well absolutely it did i think the
the perspective that jason kenney has
been on the ballot twice without
actually being up for re-election is
absolutely true the federal election and
now the municipal election the alberta
premier tweeted his congratulations to
the incoming mayors but he's unlikely to
find new allies in either city hall both
have been highly critical of the
province's covit 19 response
gonda is the first woman to be elected
as mayor of calgary but she will not be
alone in city chambers after the last
election there were just three women on
city council in calgary and two in
edmonton now in calgary there are five
women including the mayor and eight
women on city council in edmonton
bringing gender parity across alberta's
biggest cities for the very first time
more historic achievements from an
election that produced many
heather there was also a referendum in
alberta yesterday about equalization
voters were asked whether canada should
remove a commitment from the
constitution to redistribute wealth
among the provinces premier jason kenney
says alberta pays too much he says it's
unfair even though he was in the federal
government when the equalization formula
was agreed to
it's complicated did he get what he
wanted heather well we won't have
official results until next week because
some municipalities haven't made their
numbers public yet but we do know how
people in calgary red deer lethbridge
and medicine hat have voted and most
have voted yes now will this change
anything no alberta can't vote its way
out of the federal equalization program
but the premier says a strong mandate
could help the province with its
position a stronger position more
leverage if you will as it tries to
negotiate a new deal with ottawa donna
all right heather euryx west in calgary
tonight thanks albertans also got a say
on whether to move to permanent daylight
saving time the change would eliminate
the need to change the clocks twice a
year province-wide results are due on
october 26th if the majority of people
vote yes the change will take effect
next fall and calgary voters were also
asked whether they want to reintroduce
fluoride to the city's drinking water it
has long been a contentious issue in
calgary this is the seventh time it's
been on the ballot yesterday a majority
of calgarians voted to bring it back
though the result is non-binding and the
new city council will make the final
decision
a little later i'll speak with the mayor
elect of calgary about why she thinks
she won and bridging divides in alberta
politics
in saskatchewan fewer than 300 new cases
of covid19 are being reported for the
second straight day that decline is good
news but it hasn't affected the
province's icus there are 83 patients
with covid19 in intensive care in
saskatchewan straining the system
patients needing critical care are now
being transferred to ontario pressure is
growing to reimpose public health
restrictions nathaniel dove reports
the fourth wave of covet 19 hit
saskatchewan hard
on monday the province began
transferring patients to ontario
infectious disease physician dr alex
wong says it was inevitable
we know informal triage is happening at
the bedside having to make hard
decisions again about who gets access to
you know sort of resources and who does
not after repeatedly setting daily case
count records new infections have
finally started to plateau but icu
admissions keep going up
wong says the province needs gathering
size restrictions on monday
saskatchewan's chief doctor agreed i
would certainly strongly recommend that
this is the time when we think of all
private gadgets in the home keep them to
a small consistent two or three
households only premier scott mo has
repeatedly said he won't impose new
restrictions city councilors in
saskatoon the provincial hot spot are
now exploring if they can create their
own the fact that we're the only
jurisdiction that doesn't have gathering
size restrictions even alberta does it
doesn't make sense to me
and things can still get worse the covet
19 viral load in saskatoon's wastewater
doubled since last week up 109 percent a
toxicologist says thanksgiving helped
the virus spread hospitalizations lag a
week to two weeks behind our numbers so
by the time people get sick end up sick
enough to be in the hospital and get
diagnosed takes some time saskatchewan
has finally asked for federal help
global news asked what exactly that
means in terms of new frontline staff
the government only said it takes a
strategic approach when it comes to
resource requests
wong says the fact that it comes weeks
after health care workers started
calling for aid shows politics are
guiding the province's pandemic response
if there's no further action then we're
just kind of going to see how it goes
we're going to be on our own
and facing a harsh reality that could
cost more lives
nathaniel dove global news saskatoon
there are lots of questions emerging
about covid19 vaccines for children
under the age of 12. pfizer has applied
to health canada to get them approved
for use the company says the formulation
for kids is the same as it is for adults
though kids would get a lower dose but
there is lots of other information
parents are still waiting for abigail
beeman reports
this far into the pandemic people are
exhausted
and the planners are exhausted and the
vaccinators are exhausted and so there's
not a lot of patience or tolerance for
delays and uncertainty and questions but
uncertainty and questions are exactly
what people planning for pediatric
vaccinations like kelly grindod are
facing late fall we're going to be doing
flu shots we're probably going to be
doing some third doses and high risk
groups and also kids vaccines so this is
all happening at once like the adult
vaccine how kids get the shot will be up
to each province or public health unit
we want to make sure it's equitable and
accessible to all children so it needs
to be in child friendly spaces while the
federal government has a contract with
pfizer that includes pediatric shots
ottawa is not yet saying how fast
they'll arrive if and when the under 12
pfizer vaccine gets the green light from
health canada the dosage for kids is one
third of the adult dose the biggest
question right now can kids be given a
smaller dosage of the same adult vaccine
drawing up pediatric doses from the
existing vials
is not something that is recommended at
this point
with for a number of reasons
we also understand from pfizer that
there's actual
the formulation has shifted but in a
statement to global news pfizer says the
formulation of the vaccine itself is the
same other than the dose being
administered based on the child's age
pfizer says it's working on a different
presentation 10 doses per vial a
different label and different color cap
for kids the public health agency of
canada did not offer clarification of dr
tam's comments by deadline it does make
for less precise dosing the primary
concern is are we able to precisely give
the amount of vaccine that's been
studied in pediatrics to kids if we're
using one third of the adult dose health
canada says it's making sure benefits of
the vaccine outweigh the risks for this
age group before any approval but isn't
offering a timeline abigail beeman
global news ottawa the rcmp is now
working with haitian and american police
to free a canadian who's one of 17
missionaries and their families
kidnapped over the weekend the rcmp is
not providing any more detail a
notorious haitian gang is demanding a 17
million dollar u.s ransom 1 million for
each hostage the missionaries were in
the country with the u.s based
non-profit group christian aid
ministries five children between the
ages of 8 months and 15 years are among
those abducted the identity of the
canadian has not been made public
former conservative prime minister
stephen harper on his way to saudi
arabia says he remains proud to have
negotiated a billion dollar deal to sell
the kingdom armored vehicles in a
statement posted on twitter harper says
he is also proud that this constructive
relationship helped secure jobs for
canadians through the largest export
manufacturing contract in canada's
history the 15 billion dollar deal was
signed in 2014 it involved manufacturing
hundreds of light armored vehicles
equipped with machine guns and cannon at
an ontario plant when justin trudeau was
elected he vowed he'd tried to cancel
the contract but later said the
cancellation fees were prohibitive human
rights groups have long opposed the sale
because of saudi arabia's poor human
rights record and warn it could use the
weapons against civilians harper who now
runs a consulting business will visit
saudi arabia almost three years to the
day after saudi agents murdered
washington post columnist jamal
khashoggi
kovid cases climb in the uk coming up
what's fueling the spike and why things
could get worse
plus have pot will travel one couple's
non-traditional way to get to their
wedding
in texas a close call on a runway this
small plane with 21 people on board was
attempting to take off but hit a fence
rolled off the runway and erupted in
flames everyone on board did manage to
escape safely only two people reported
minor injuries
there is pressure from some public
health doctors in the uk to reimpose
restrictions because cases of covet 19
are on the rise again there have been an
average of 43 000 new cases each day for
the last week the highest since
restrictions were lifted in july
hospital age hospitalizations and deaths
are also rising though they are nowhere
near the level at the start of the
pandemic
britain was the first western country to
roll out vaccines but that early success
could be part of the troubles today
redmond shannon explains
[Applause]
it's been exactly three months since
england left behind its last level of
lockdown no more vaccine passports
social distancing or mask mandates
as expected infections rose but with a
largely vaccinated population serious
cases and deaths stayed low but now
they're surging again a lot of the usual
symptoms and some of the odd ones which
i wasn't expecting canadian infectious
disease expert roland kayo is among the
increasing numbers of people in
isolation with covid19 here he says the
uk's early vaccine success is partly why
infections are now rising again so the
waning of vaccines is something we have
always expected okay this this is what
happens with any immune response you do
not keep it up forever all right the
question was how long it was and the
evidence over the past few months is
that it does decline and a substantial
people number of people have reduced
protection after about six months
diminishing effectiveness will also
depend on the type of vaccine the uk is
rolling out booster shots to the
vulnerable and healthcare workers
evidence from israel suggests that will
re-flatten the curve but britain only
recently started vaccinating under 18s
and that could be a problem at the
moment the epidemic is still being
driven in the uk by teenagers and
younger adults it's clear that the
vaccination program in 12 and 15 year
olds is
not going very well the worry is the
autumn winter is going to is going to
get very very messy the british
government says it is keeping a close
eye on the so-called delta plus variant
which experts say is slightly more
transmissible and resilient it says if
the pressure on the national health
service becomes too much this winter
then vaccine passports and masks may
return
donna all right redmond shannon in
london thank you
a couple in southern india didn't let
flash flooding ruin their wedding day
they found a way to adapt the bride and
groom sailed to the ceremony sitting in
this big metal cooking pot they floated
to the temple through muddy water two
men steering the way some members of the
family apparently swam other use others
used another pot to get there
the couple dry and hopefully living
happily ever after
meet calgary's new mayor ahead a
one-on-one with jody gondeck about her
historic election win
calgary made headlines in 2010 when it
elected the first muslim mayor of a
major north american city and now it's
done it again electing the first female
mayor in the city's history jyoti gandek
is of punjabi heritage and so is the new
mayor of edmonton amrajeet sohi if this
doesn't finally obliterate national
stereotypes of alberta as some kind of
racist backwater writes calgary herald
columnist dawn braid perhaps nothing
ever will well with me from calgary is
jody gondeck mayor-elect
first let me say congratulations to you
thank you so much
can you reflect a bit on your victory
what was it do you think about you and
your campaign the appeal to calgarians
well i think we offered people something
to vote for my campaign team and i have
been very clear from the beginning that
there must be a vision that's
communicated to calgarians and i think
the people of calgary embraced it they
wanted to hear more about what we would
do for resiliency in this city and they
demonstrated that they liked what they
heard by coming out to vote
you have a phd in urban sociology i've
read you've worked as an academic why
did you decide to make the leap to
public office and run for mayor did
something happen that made you say this
is it i'm running
you know it's been an interesting
journey falling in love with this
concept of city building
it started many years ago when i picked
up a couple of projects my dad had left
unfinished when he passed away quite
unfortunately in 2003.
and as i dug in to do some of that work
with his friends and colleagues i
realized that
there was a calling for me in public
service and i did a lot of volunteer
roles in and around the city and my
communities and in 2017 i looked back at
what i had been trying to do to
influence from the outside and i thought
maybe it was time to get a seat at the
table i felt well prepared at that time
and now with four years of counsel under
my belt i feel incredibly well prepared
to serve calgarians as their mayor
i know premier jason kenney has
congratulated you are you ideologically
aligned in any way and what sort of
relationship do you hope to have with
him
i think the greatest alignment that our
city and the provincial government could
have is one where we realize that we all
serve the same people so if we can count
on their assistance in providing the
supports that people need with public
health with child care access to housing
then we can help be that economic engine
again that carries us forward you know i
talked to nahad nenshi last month about
the toxic political atmosphere these
days how hostile and vicious some people
can be how much does that concern you
and and how do you think you'll push
back against it
it is quite concerning and i think a lot
of people who ran as candidates for the
first time in this election
realized just how ugly it can be but i
have a lot of faith that
we have a brighter future ahead i think
people are incredibly optimistic about
it and i think people have realized that
we need to band together to make sure
we're stamping out the voices that try
to be louder than ours
all right jyoti gondek mayor elect of
calgary thanks so much
thanks for having me on
up next rumblings from the red planet
what those sounds mean for exploration
on mars
a remarkable find off the coast of
israel a diver on a weekend treasure
hunt discovered this a sword experts
believe is roughly 900 years old dating
back to the crusades it's about a meter
long and was exposed when sands shifted
in the shallow water of a cove known for
sheltering ships the sword believed to
be made of iron will be x-rayed and
cleaned and maybe reveal clues about the
crusader who once carried it from an eye
on the distant past to an ear on the
distant present the first photograph
ever taken on the surface of mars was
beamed back to earth 45 years ago and
now sounds from the red planet captured
by nasa's perseverance rover are giving
scientists a deeper understanding of
what it's like to roam around up there
mike trolley explains
if your car made a racket like this
you'd get it checked out but nasa named
its mars rover perseverance not
rolls-royce
so all that clanking and scratching
they could care less yeah it's it's not
engineered for you know comfort
so there's definitely sounds of you know
moving up and down it's got a lot of
metal so there's going to be creaking
and groaning a little bit nasa has now
had a few months to study the hours of
sounds first recorded by the rover the
first audio ever captured on another
planet it's not as sexy as the lander's
descent or the subsequent drone flight
but hearing the winds of mars
adds to our sensory feel of another
world it doesn't really tie into the
search for life or anything like that
but it tells us that there were things
that we had predicted about the
atmosphere that we didn't quite get
right nasa scientists knew the martian
atmosphere was thin so they expected
high pitched sounds would either
disappear or appear muffled for example
this is what birds sound like on earth
and to be clear they haven't found birds
on mars but if they did this is what
you'd hear
what surprised them was how far sound
travels on the red planet the mars
helicopter was 80 meters away
yet the rover's microphones were still
able to pick it up proving science
doesn't just look cool with all of our
upcoming uh missions to you know
jupiter's moons different planets around
the solar system i think it would be a
nice um you know soundtrack you know
sounds of the solar system and here i
thought we already had that
[Music]
mike global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's york
canada is near the village of packingham
ontario west of ottawa we'd love to see
your canada please email it to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]